Hoss Gomez - beautifu I am so [ __ ]
excited
we're playing alien isolation it's not
every day we get a triple horror game
that is genuinely exciting anymore it
felt like those things were over for a
while like there weren't even paying
attention to us anymore so this is it
this is the game I've been waiting for
for such a long time I'm so excited to
play it I think it's gonna be amazing
this is gonna be such a good series I
can't wait to take you bros on with this
to hit this series really off really
well once this video gets 70k bros
liking it I'll upload part two right
away just to keep a good pace from the
first day I think this is gonna be so
awesome I'm so excited to be sharing
this with you bros this is the part
where I'm just like I [ __ ] love what I
do
I [ __ ] love YouTube I'm so excited to
play this like I don't get excited for a
lot of games that's just the thing but
once I find a game that I'm genuinely
excited about then holy [ __ ] let's
change the settings just [ __ ] kidding
no one gives a [ __ ] let's play alien
isolation on medium because if I die you
bros are gonna get pissed so I have the
brightness up a little bit because I
have like lightning towards me and that
makes it harder for me to see plus the
gameplay on YouTube kind of looks darker
than it is because of all the whiteness
around it I'm also half of this in 1080p
for you bros so it's higher quality than
usual I am it should be okay I have
really slow internet so you know it
genuinely I try to avoid that but so I
might have to here I might actually have
to go back on that but yeah Sega
presents Thank You Sega in association
with 20th Century Fox Thank You 20th
century Lord of the commercial starship
Nostromo
third officer reporting who is she
the other members of the crew Caine
Lambert Parker Brett
[Music]
Ash
and captain Dallas are dead cargo and
ship destroyed I should reach the
frontier in about six weeks with a
little luck the network will pick me up
the network what is that
this is ripley last survivor of the
Nostromo
signing off
annually in isolation I used to have
nightmares from the åland in from the
movies when I was a kid I don't even
know man
so yeah I don't even know about this one
I'm gonna get neighbors from this one
it's this space and aliens just freak me
out
Ripley oh so we are playing as Ripley
I'm Samuels I work for the company their
company it's about your mother
we think we may have found her Amanda
an avid voice a commercial vessel the
anisa Dora has recovered what we
believed to be the flight recorder unit
of the Nostromo where
Zita reticula what did it tell you we
don't know the unit was taken to
Sevastopol station
it's proprietorial material so the
company wants it to be collected as soon
as possible
Sevastopol is a supply depot in the
region it's a permanent Freeport I know
what it is
transits arranged there's a courier ship
called the Torrens heading out that way
in two days we're going to travel out we
me and another exactly and you if you're
willing hmm look Ripley when this job
came across my desk I read the case
history what about it
my mom used to work there and I know
while you're working in the region where
she went missing you're still looking oh
yeah I've been cleared to offer you a
place on the Torrance if you want to
come along maybe there'll be some
closure for you
interesting how how the game looks the
graphics I like the graphics what can I
say it's interesting so far I'm so
[ __ ] into this as well what deaf what
what is going on Oh hallo I'm naked
please sign in what the hell we just
woke up oh oh this must be like well
space cocoons so we're sleeping these
when we travel in space
is that it let's sign in welcome a
Ripley so we are playing as a girl in
the beginning and our ship is torrents I
love this music yeah what are you doing
here mr. duck I told you never to come
back here how dare you say that to my
face you son of a [ __ ] well I see
Jurgen made it on the ship - great
choice of magazines love the eighties
feel of the soundtrack it's [ __ ]
amazing love this so far cool keel
all right well let's get dressed in
personal storage hello
this is so [ __ ] immersive so far I'm
so into this what is this though what is
that space toilet let's take a [ __ ]
Wow toilets in the future are amazing
but science has brought us so far I just
took all that you want all right we're
done
where is our clothes crew roster crew ID
we just sign in everyone is signed in
apparently what is this core system
outfit what is this where zero three why
what does that mean oh well how
convenient
there we go let's get dressed
that was quick and easy and we're
wearing converse amazing whoa
space couches they look amazing space
magazines they look awesome can't
believe they still these paper though
you'd think they wouldn't do that
oh so this is safe section same station
I got a new station uh yeah all right
doing good how does it work as a map
speak to Taylor over there all right
Wally what are you doing here Wally get
out of my house get off my car Wally
which way was it this way yeah and then
a right cool costumes look at that
awesome I hope we get to wear this this
should be it speak to Samuels
all right let's speak to Samuels
he's over here I got it while I didn't
work out oh he's here
[ __ ] never mind never mind I'm gonna
speak to Sam oils by various he doesn't
know we're here let's sneak up on him
Oh how did you know I was just
inspecting the Torrens facilities are
well maintained I realize it's a very
similar model to the Nostromo yes
I've worked engineering jobs on ships
like this of course it's Taylor okay
she's not a seasoned traveler - Sally
I'll go check on her
there's something about his eyes and
what do you mean with I don't need as
much sleep as others shits and stuff I'm
like whoa what are these should I press
them okay just like mash my face on them
well let's let's check on Taylor then I
suppose this way
Taylor Taylor oh why can't we just be
together keep forgetting the way there
we go that's a wrench did you know that
the wrenches are Swedish invention
you're welcome
first for it for it for branches and me
[Music]
that Taylor she looks like that girl
from oranges and you black good morning
god British people was so cynical I
don't know how you people put up with
hypersleep regularly you get used to it
I don't do long hall very often most
legal execs don't travel further than
the coffee machine I'm surprised
weyland-yutani felt the need to send
legal at all the loss of the Nostromo in
its cargo cost the company a lot of
money it's important we find out what
happens if I can close the case with a
conclusive accident report it'll look
great with my superiors I'm sorry that
was insensitive
realize your mother has been missing for
15 years and you it's okay we'll both
get what we want right have you seen
Samuels he's probably been up for hours
yeah I talked to him okay all the
objectives are complete explore the
Torrance okay looks like we're up all
right he was fast but I wanted to check
out the space potato how does it work I
love this [ __ ] so cool like a mixture of
modern and old I like that how can I
have a spaceship but a boombox this big
like what the [ __ ] oh they're playing
Justin Bieber again space beeps that's
they call them some things just
shouldn't have gone into the future want
to know what all these I hippo
hit Papa Potamus globe like Lola Foster
was topping up the top of this as ghost
Rodriguez I'm not a large water dwelling
animal where'd you get that but he
passes well I shouldn't read people's
personal stuff the Nostromo incident so
that's where we're going hey Taylor
I got your case request it may take a
while to dig out the files and the
incident happened before my time at the
company some a bit fuzzy on the details
oh so this is Taylor - Taylor in 2022
the weyland-yutani cargo vessels that US
blah blah blah Nostromo went missing no
trace was found of its cargo recruit
apart from new science opposite the rest
of the crew had worked together these
are all their names and these are all
the names that that I was saying we're
missing in the beginning what the [ __ ]
weyland-yutani lost a lot of money from
it it's a bit of black mark in history
so we were part of this yeah we were the
warrant officer of it interesting it's a
bit pug get the impression they don't
like to mention it anyway I'll try and
find the files later
by some of the points if you want I can
help people go through them maybe some
of your luck will rub off on me
I'll hear upstairs heaven I own you for
something big Saul that soul from
Breaking Bad and I don't feel like
reading that interesting so we're
looking for a mom and we'd be heading to
this Nostromo [ __ ] and we have a black
past but I don't I guess that's what
makes it so badass
she was a wreck when I bought her took a
few years and a lot of contracts to
refit she pays for herself now you said
we're approaching Sebastopol station are
we dumping I believe your contact is
marshal weights is that right all hail
Sevastopol and arrange boarding with him
good let's get this done don't worry
miss Taylor routine in and out
Conner how we doing oMG loaded and
calibrated approach vector locked prep
comm so I can say hello
channel open captain does everyone have
their briefing documents you can watch
the approach on the monitors what kind
of answer was that I don't have my
documents oh there there I want to look
around a little bit first look at that
beauty so that's the planet and we're
heading to I thought there was a ship
we're going to me
what the [ __ ] is that sound guys do you
hear that
hello its it on the ship no it can't
what is she doing she's just a lawyer it
looks like he's crying or sweating you
figure they invented air conditioning in
the future especially on a spaceship
alright let's keep going
get dammit this is interesting so far oh
there it is oh so that's what they made
can we see it
switch to monitors Sevastopol love the
VHS quality monitoring it looks like
damage I don't see it punch up 74 tight
angle drydock bays screwed I can't bring
the Torrens into that this is a
commercial vessel torrents out of st.
Claire registration number MSB seven
seven six zero calling Sebastopol
traffic control we're carrying three
passengers in a weyland-yutani bond
you're holding the Nostromo flight
recorder unit we request immediate
permission to transfer the passengers
portside over
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Marshall this is the torrent say again
[Music]
oh I have a bad feeling about this
we should calm seemed pretty screwed up
so I fitted Samuel suit with a radio
booster I can only keep the Torrens in
transit for 24 hours you live hard for
my spy then safe trip
alright the outfit look so cool space
works it's the only option and it's
perfectly safe if you do what I tell you
so [ __ ] cool depressurizing
Phoenix just shadow me tailor you to
Samuels affirmative whoa
they really keep their Alien movies feel
happened here I love that you're doing
good
[Music]
[Music]
we made it
not even the [ __ ] okay we is spots great
[ __ ] great oh my god what an intro
alright Bruce I'm gonna have to end the
first part here if you enjoyed watching
like I said please feel free to leave a
like once this video hits 70 thousand L
up loaded anyone right away it's just to
keep a good pace on them so yeah I
appreciate you doing that and living in
comment on the website where you have a
comments now on the bro army forums why
not go there I usually stay active as
well it's this guy comin birth today and
I am very much looking forward to share
this series with you bros I hope you are
excited as well and I will see bros in
the next one as always stay awesome